We've finally got the first trailer for Aquaman
and let's just say I'm digging it!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm breaking down the top five moments
and easter eggs in the epic Comic Con trailer
for Aquaman.
And just before we start, if you're new here,
be sure to subscribe to stay up-to-date with
all my superhero and Comic Con videos.
The underwater world of Aquaman that director
James Wan will be bringing to the big screen
looks pretty breath-taking.
"Welcome home."
"Badass!"
"My brother has come from the surface!"
Comic book fans will likely be extremely happy
at the level of comic book accuracy, and the
world-building going on here is fantastic.
For example, those sharks and sea dragons
with their riders are amazing to see in action.
And jumping ahead in the trailer, we have
to talk about the incredible awesomeness of
the underwater war that's teased.
"I'm bringing the wrath of the Seven Seas
with me."
Let's just go back over the epicness of it
all to check the details.
Behind that huge school of sharks advancing,
there's some tentacled craft that look a bit
like squids or they may be octopus-inspired.
And as they advance on the army of giant crab
and lobster-like creatures, I love the way
these giant alligators or tylosaurs swim in
and go in for the kill on one of the crustaceans.
Talking of battles, Black Manta looks amazing.
"The war is coming to the surface and I am
bringing the wrath of the Seven Seas with
me."
This is a very comic book accurate costume
for this second villain and James Wan has
said that the movie will reveal how Black
Manta got his costume and how he can shoot
plasma beams out of his bug-eyed helmet.
The actor who plays him has said Black Manta
is simply out for revenge on Aquaman and he's
not planning to take over the world or anything
like that.
From the trailer, it looks like the cause
of Black Manta's grievance against Arthur
Curry will be when Aquaman attacks a submarine
that he's hijacked with some other mercenaries.
By the way, it looks like Black Manta will
be used as a pawn by Aquaman's main villain,
Arthur's brother Orm, who wants to bring war
to the surface world.
There's a glimpse of that when Black Manta
wreaks havoc with his laser eyes on a town's
rooftops.
Right, let's go back to the water for yet
another visual feast when Aquaman and Mera
encounter creatures from the Trench.
James Wan is a master of horror movies and
these moments are an homage to the type of
scary monsters in Creature From The Black
Lagoon.
This is a scene where the Trench people attack
a boat to kill and eat the people on board
and it looks like Aquaman and Mera are using
a flare to draw or scare them away.
The visual look of this scene is stunning
and the way the creatures swarm into the ocean
like a horde of ants to chase after Aquaman
and Mera is epic.
The filmmakers have said the Trench people
are like "the mole people of the sea".
They don't actually have any eyes, so I'm
curious to find out exactly how the flare
works to draw them away from the boat.
By the way, I'm also getting a touch of Alien
xenomorph vibes from one of the close-up shots
of the Trench creatures in the footage.
And if you enjoyed the theme in the trailer,
you might not have realised that it's actually
a cool musical easter egg to Batman v Superman,
specifically the trailer for the Ultimate
Edition.
So, overall, I really dug this trailer, but
I'm not totally sure about some of the corny
one-liners.
"That was the worst pep talk.
Ever."
Though some of them are probably gonna be
crowd-pleasers.
"Permission to come aboard?"
"We're here."
"What are you doing?"
"Wait, wait, wait!"
"She hasn't a parachute!"
"Redheads, you gotta love 'em."
Also, some of the green screen was a bit noticeable
in a few sequences, but that's pretty normal
at this stage and VFX are often improved between
trailer releases and the final theatrical
release, so hopefully that's the case here
too.
So, what do you think about the Aquaman trailer?
And what were the best moments for you?
Let's discuss more in the comments and do
leave a like if you enjoyed this video.
Tap left for more movie breakdowns including
easter eggs you missed in the Glass trailer
plus my Godzilla 2 trailer analysis.
Or tap right for more superhero and Comic
Con videos.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!